this character is one of the bravest
characters I've ever seen and she's not
an action star who wields a lot of
weapons or jumps through explosions or
anything like that she's just a simple
mother who wants to save her child that
is mrs. Brisby from the secret of NIMH
again one of my favorite movies of all
time
by far the greatest strength of a film
is its main character a small Mouse who
discovers an evolutionary and scientific
breakthrough tries to find a way to
protect her son from being killed by an
illness she earns trust and respect
because she's the widow of Jonathan
Brisby who you would usually see as the
main character in a film like this the
hero the action star the guy that saves
the day but instead we focus on someone
much more gentler and kinder someone
who's not used to action someone who's
not used to suspenseful situations but
will face them nonetheless for me it's
not just the kind boy's gentle nature
and dedication that makes her stand out
so much what makes a truly strong great
character is the danger they're willing
to go up against but what many people
forget is that danger isn't something
you compare to other stories danger is
what you compared to what the person in
this life normally faces and how they're
willing to take it on we've seen other
heroes battle foot soldiers and monsters
the forces of nature and whatever else
can be thrown at them well if you see
the hero just sort of fight through them
with ease it's not very interesting if
the character is so used to it and not
afraid it establishes that person has
little to lose with mrs. Brisby it's
made very clear what she has to lose not
just her life but the life of her child
and it's also made very clear that her
day to day world is just looking after
her children slashed trying to provide
for them so when you do see her afraid
or you do see her cowering you know how
much the fear gets to her you know how
terrified she is to be in this situation
but she does it anyway she stands up to
it she keeps talking she keeps going
into all these creepy places she keeps
moving forward even though so many
forces try to fight her back this movie
realizes that a care
strength that only comes from how real
the danger is and to her the danger is
very real and very hard to get through
but she's still willing to risk it all
with a kind nature courageous heart and
undying love of those she cares about
you can show Optimus Prime jumping on
top of buildings and slicing through
other machines but it's nowhere near as
impressive or suspenseful as our main
character just going up against an owl
because it makes very clear what there
is to be lost
because of who she places her value in
and how much value she places in him and
the more wide-eyed and afraid she looks
the more you realize how much she could
be sacrificing it's hard to even know
what else to say about her it seems like
those virtues are enough they're very
strong virtues that I don't think people
always give enough credit for they do
make great heroes they're not
muscle-bound and have a lot of distinct
fighting moves but through their
vulnerability that's displayed they also
at the exact same time display their
strengths she's a wonderful character
thy root for every single moment she's
on screen
I love how frightful she is but the fact
that she never gives up despite of it
and that the greater and greater the
danger gets the more and more she'll try
to get through it there's a lot that
I've learned from her and as I keep
watching
I get the feeling I'll learn even more